[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'ère post déj
malgré des avancées majeures dans la
lutte contre l'état islamique la menace
terroriste est loin d'être éradiquée
dans chaque partie du monde
elle a ses propres spécificités le
califat vit des moments difficiles mais
on est encore loin du dépôt généralisée
des armes
car si le leader du groupe abou bakr al
bagdadi a bien été assassiné en octobre
dernier
dans le même temps l'onu met en garde
contre la résurgence de l'état islamique
au moyen-orient en effet de nombreux
groupes terroristes inspirés par des
semaines des attaques sanglantes à
travers le monde
c'est le cas notamment de l'état
islamique province du khorassan qui
sévit en asie ou encore de boko haram
très actif en afrique or l'activité
terroriste mondiale ne se limite pas aux
fidèles de dèche des talibans al-qaïda
est encore al shabab mais eux aussi des
attaques meurtrières contre des civils
pourtant le visage du terrorisme change
en fonction des régions et des pays où
ils s'évitent l'union européenne ou
encore les états unis la le terrorisme
est souvent inspirées par des idées
d'extrême droite
nombreux sont les cas d'attentât
perpétrée par des combattants solitaire
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les dernières données
mondiale à propos du terrorisme c'est le
blitz selon le global terrorisme windex
2019 les progrès dans la lutte
antiterroriste sont bien notable pour la
quatrième année consécutive le nombre de
victimes du terrorisme est en baisse
quinze mille neuf cent cinquante deux
personnes ont été tuées dans des
attentats en 2018 soit une baisse de 15%
en un an
malgré cela le nombre de pays affectés
par le terrorisme reste alarmant plus de
soixante dix états ont enregistré au
moins un décès lié au terrorisme
en 2018 le triste record est détenu par
l'afghanistan 7379 arguant sont morts
dans des attentats en 2018 soit la
moitié de toutes les victimes du
terrorisme dans le monde
ensuite vient le nigeria avec un peu
plus de 2000 morts et ensuite l'irak
le nombre de victimes du terrorisme est
supérieur à 1000 par ailleurs dèche
ce n'est plus le groupe terroriste le
plus meurtrier dans le monde avec 1328
victimes
pour la seule année 2010 8 les talibans
ont pris sa place et ont tué presque
quatre fois plus de victimes soit 6103
personnes en 2018 l'allié le plus
puissante des shs l'état islamique
province du corps à son vient en
troisième position dans ce triste
classement avec 1060 victimes en 2018
c'est son année la plus meurtrière
depuis la création la lutte
antiterroriste commence enfin à porter
ses fruits à l'échelle mondiale le
nombre de victimes est en baisse et
l'activité terroriste est au ralenti des
résultats qui découle largement deux
lourdes défaites que subit l'état
islamique au moyen orient considéré
souvent comme le noyau du terrorisme
mondial le groupe perd en octobre 2019
son leader abou bakr al bagdadi
cependant il est encore trop tôt pour
crier victoire le nu mais encore en
garde contre les tentatives de dèche
pour restaurer son potentiel
ses partisans eux aussi se montre très
actif en asie c'est l'état islamique
provence du corps à 100 ou en afrique
boko haram les deux organisations sont
classés parmi les plus violentes au
monde
mais aujourd'hui ce sont les talibans
qui sont les plus meurtriers
ce jour c'est le groupe terroriste le
plus actif avec plus de 7000 personnes
tuées pour la seule année 2010 8 al
qaïda inquiète aussi en asie ce groupe
entretient des liens très étroits avec
les talibans en afrique certaines
cellules terroristes mènent des attaques
sous son drapeau
c'est le cas notamment du groupe de
soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans ou
encore d'al shabab l'union européenne ou
les états unis aucune région au monde
n'est aujourd'hui épargné ici les
évêques sont souvent perpétrées par des
combattants solitaire cependant la
région la moins touchée par le
terrorisme reste l'amérique latine
quelques rares attaques isolées sont
menées par des mouvements locaux de
guérilla ou des indigènes
alors quelles sont les particularités du
terrorisme selon les différentes parties
du monde en est on dans la lutte anti
des ch
enfin comment le terrorisme mondial at
il évolué au cours de ces dernières
années
afin d'y voir plus clair nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en discuter avec madame
caroline galak terros géopolitologue et
présidente de géo pragma madame galak
terros bonjour bonjour d'abord alors les
positions de dèche sont affaiblis mais
le groupe n'est pas complètement vaincu
faut-il craindre selon vous une
résurgence de l'état islamique
ce n'est même pas une résurgence parce
qu'il n'est pas mort du tout on peut
dire que sa stratégie de
territorialisation oui on a pris un coup
en syrie et en irak
mais l'éclatement a lieu
j'allais dire les franchises terroriste
maintenance ou une infinité de petits
groupuscules se poursuit que ce soit en
amérique
que ce soit par don en afrique que ce
soit
dans tout le moyen-orient derrière rien
n'est terminé
donc on est très très loin d'en avoir
fini avec des jld mais ça ne prendra pas
forcément ni ce nom ni cette appellation
nicéphore mais là c'est un phénomène
polymorphe et c'est un phénomène qui
s'adapte remarquablement d'abord au
soutien qu'on lui fournit deuxièmement à
l'évolution de l'histoire troisièmement
au conflit des grandes puissances dont
il s'est très bien tiré parti donc on
est on est très très loin de la fin
justement je voulais vous parler de
cette fragmentation de dèche
il ya plusieurs groupements terroristes
qui lui prêtent encore allégeance
aujourd'hui parmi celles ci par exemple
jamaal charles route daoula l'une des
plus dangereuses que vont-ils faire
maintenant alors que les positions de
l'état islamique sont affaiblis vont-ils
agir comme des terroristes indépendant
alors y at il des terroristes
indépendant vos outils saint etienne
passion qu'est ce qu'ils vont prendre
une forme de lutte particulière où ça
sera quand même dans cet esprit de
l'état islamique non mais là les gens
c'est utile l'allégeance et utile
d'abord parce qu'elle donne une
légitimation idéologique souvent à des
combats qui ne sont pas franchement qui
sont des cobayes des combats pour des
ressources des combats économique des
combats pour la prédation de certaines
ressources dans certains pays et qui ont
besoin de cette espèce de parrainage
symbolique qui est une manière d'attirer
les gens et qui est une manière aussi
d'attirer des soutiens parce que
on n'est pas terroriste comme ça par
l'opération du saint-esprit il faut des
moyens faut des armes
il faut des véhicules il faut il faut
plein de choses il faut de l'argent il
faut donc il y a certes cette
fragmentation mais je ne crois pas à
l'indépendance il peut y avoir pour
certaines causes particulières des
groupes qui tout en se revendiquant d'un
parrainage des chiens on va dire
poursuivre leur agenda
je parle de l'idéologie est ce que ça
sera toujours cette même idéologiques
revendiquer des ch
mais l'idéologie c'est la 4éme isme
religieux voilà les l'idéologie ccc
l'islam conquérant djihadistes qui doit
l'emporter par la pureté de ses valeurs
sous différentes formes sur la
perversion la déliquescence idéologique
et morale d'un occident et de tous ses
succédanés ça c'est l'idéologie
la réalité c'est que c'est bien souvent
des individus qui cherchent le pouvoir
comme tout le monde ils cherchent le
pouvoir la puissance la domination la
captation des ressources donc bien sûr
cette idéologie existe mais elle est
très très largement instrumentale la
question ce qu'il faut que nous nous
arrêtions de l'instrumentaliser
madame caractères hausse merci bonjour
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
mais nous reviendrons vers vous dans la
deuxième partie de l'émission
merci
l'état islamique est il complètement
vaincu rien n'est moins sûr le lieu a
dénombré plus de vingt mille terroristes
présents actuellement sur le sol syrien
et irakien
une menace plus que sérieuse selon le
secrétaire général adjoint de l'onu
l'état islamique a poursuivi ses
tentatives de renaître et de restaurer
son potentiel afin de mener des
opérations internationales complexes
les cellules régionales de neige
continue à suivre leurs stratégies de
consolidation dans les zones de conflit
en exploitant les problèmes locaux
cependant l échelle mondiale la lutte
antiterroriste en a porté ses fruits
globalement le nombre de morts dus à des
attentats est en baisse l'activité
terroriste
elle connaît son plus bas niveau depuis
2011 c'est notamment le résultat des
coups durs portés à l'état islamique en
syrie en irak sans oublier l'assassinât
du leader du groupe djihadiste abou bakr
al bagdadi pour la première fois depuis
2014 l'état islamique cède sa place au
talent et banc en tant que
l'organisation terroriste la plus
meurtrière du monde
ces derniers constituent un vaste
mouvement djihadiste qui sévit
principalement en afghanistan
et c'est d'ailleurs à cause de lui que
l'asie est aujourd'hui devenue la région
la plus touchée par le terrorisme
aujourd'hui les talibans sont actifs sur
environ les deux tiers du territoire
afghan près de 20% du pays se trouve
sous leur contrôle
leur objectif est de conquérir la
totalité de l'afghanistan et d'en faire
un émirat islamique
les talibans refusent le dialogue direct
avec le gouvernement afghan qu'ils
considèrent comme illégitime selon
l'institut pour l'économie et la paix en
2018 les talibans étaient responsables
de 4 des attentats les plus meurtriers
sur cinq dans le monde en 2019 leur
activité devient encore plus cinglante
entre janvier et septembre 2019 la
mission de l'onu en afghanistan a
recensé plus de 900 ventes de civils
tués et 2009 101 blessés
en effet la campagne présidentielle
afghane bat son plein et les talibans
font tout pour empêcher les futures
élections mi septembre
un double attentat a retenti en
afghanistan le premier visant meeting
électoral du président ashraf ghani et
l'autre se produit à kaboul au moins 48
personnes sont tuées plus qu'actif sur
le territoire afghan les talibans
maintiennent des liens très forts avec
un autre groupe terroriste présents dans
le pays à savoir al qaïda c'est que les
relations entre les deux groupes sont
mutuellement avantageux
selon le dernier rapport onusien al
qaeda fournit des ressources et entraîne
les talibans en échange d'une protection
les deux organisations sont également
actifs dans d'autres pays asiatiques
notamment au pakistan où les cinq
membres supposés d'al qaïda ont été
arrêtés en décembre 2019 selon les
autorités locales il planifiait des
attentats contre les forces d'ordre
pakistanaise hostiles aux talibans et à
al qaïda les partisans de l'état
islamique constitue un autre pilier de
l'activité terroriste dans l'asie du sud
leurs branches orientale appelés l'état
islamique province du corps à 100 fait
partie des organisations terroristes les
plus meurtrières dans le monde
dans son viseur se trouve l'afghanistan
le pakistan le tadjikistan et même
l'inde fondé en 2015 par l'ancien
commandant des taliban pakistanais hafiz
saeed khan
le groupe est composé de nombreuses
cellules terroristes call ayant prêté
allégeance à l'état ni leur objectif est
de reconstituer la province médiavale du
grand encore à 100 pour l'intégrer dans
le califat un objectif démesuré pour un
groupe qui n'est d'ailleurs pas si
important selon les dernières
estimations et comprend entre 600 et 800
hommes qui mènent des attaques
meurtrières dans la quasi-totalité de
l'asie du sud avril 2019 un attentat est
commis au pakistan adjani se fait
exploser au marché au moins 20 personnes
sont tuées
40 sont blessés en novembre les
militants du groupe mène une autre
attaque violente à la frontière entre
l'ouzbékistan et le tadjikistan
environ 17 personnes sont tuées sur le
point de contrôle entre les deux pays
pourtant l'asie du sud n'est pas la
seule région asiatique frappée par les
opérations des alliés de l'état
islamique
la menace terroriste pèse aussi lourd ge
sur l'asie du sud est
un indonésie c'est déjà un chat route
daoula une coalition d'une douzaine de
groupuscules islamistes ayant prêté
allégeance à neige c'est ce groupe qui
se cache derrière les attaques les plus
sanglantes de ces dernières années l'une
d'entre elle se produit en mai 2018
deux familles liées à ajman charjah ou
la comète une série d'attentats violents
visant à la fois trois églises et un
poste de police
une troisième famille fait exploser
apparemment par accident une bombe dans
un appartement
bilan 28 morts et 57 blessés c'est la
série d' attaque la plus violente 1-1
données
si depuis plus d'une décennie quels sont
les autres groupes terroristes qui
sévissent à travers le monde comment le
terrorisme at il évolué ces dernières
années peut-on vraiment parler du déclin
de l'état islamique
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
malgré une lutte acharnée contre des shu
la menace terroriste n'est pas éradiquée
aux quatre coins du monde de nombreux
groupes terroristes continuent de mener
des attentats meurtriers contre les
populations locales
beaucoup d'entre eux prennent toujours
allégeance à l'état islamique
autrefois organisation la plus
meurtrière du monde l'histoire de neige
commence avec l'apparition du groupe
terroriste a while jihad en irak en 1999
en 2004 ce mouvement prêtent allégeance
à al qaïda et en octobre 2006 il
fusionne avec plusieurs autres aux
cellules radical et adopte le nom d'
état islamique en irak
son but ultime est de conquérir des
territoires en irak et au delà afin de
créer un califat islamique
au début ces succès sont modestes mais
le retrait des troupes américaines
d'irak en 2007 et le début de la guerre
civile syrienne en 2011 vont renforcer
l'émergence du groupe islamique dans la
région dès 2012 d'achever son apparition
en syrie et prend dès 2013 le nom d'
état islamique en irak et au levant
conquérant de plus en plus de territoire
syrien et irakien le groupe s'attaque au
civil comme aux autres groupes radicaux
et se fait connaître par sa cruauté
fort de ses victoires il proclame en
juin 2014 l'établissement du califat sur
ces espaces avec son chef abou bakr al
bagdadi en tant que qualif sa réputation
commence à raisonner en dehors de ses
frontières aux djihadistes syriens
irakiens s'ajoutent progressivement des
ressortissants des autres pays arabes
mais aussi d'occident dèche met en place
un état autoritaire il possède ses
propres institutions ses lois et sa
justice le tout régie par les principes
de la charia sur le terrain
l'organisation fait preuve d'une
véritable barbare
à l'égard des populations civiles
surtout non musulmanes décapitation
esclavage sexuel trafic d'êtres humains
deviennent pratique courante afin de
mettre un terme à l'expansion des
islamistes les états unis lancent en
août 2014
les premières frappes contre d'âge en
irak puis en syrie sans pourtant obtenir
l'accord du président syrien bachar al
assad
au même moment il appelle à la création
d'une coalition internationale anti
terroriste près de 60 pays la rejoignent
les premières cibles de la coalition sur
les principaux épicentre djihadisme
notamment jaca devenue capitale
autoproclamée de dèche
dans le même temps en irak le mouvement
poursuit ses conquêtes et contrôle en
2015 30 % du territoire irakien et 70%
du territoire syrien
finalement en octobre 2015 c'est la
russie qui se joint aux combats à
l'appel du président syrien bachar al
assad
attaqué de tous les côtés l'état
islamique n'abandonne pas ses positions
en 2015 il est à la tête de plusieurs
grandes villes de l'irak et de syrie
mossoul irak à ramadi et palmyre au même
moment son influence s'étend au delà de
son califat en effet des groupes
militants islamistes prêtent allégeance
à des shows tels que boko haram au
nigeria abou sayyaf aux philippines et
en sarre bayt al mc 10 en egypte et
territoires de ces groupes sont alors
considérés comme des provinces de d'âge
c'est aussi en 2015 que des gens
commencent à propager la terreur au delà
du territoire qu'il contrôle des
attentats meurtriers sont commis en
france en belgique en tunisie en libye
et au liban et montre bien la puissance
organisationnelle et financière du
groupe
à cette époque la pression
internationale ne faiblit pas en 2016
soutenu par la coalition américaine les
forces démocratiques syriennes kurde
parviennent à reconquérir mmm fiche en
2017 l'armée syrienne avec l'appui de la
russie fait sa première grande victoire
à la reconquête de la ville historique
de palmyre puis à l'est
et des eraser vers la fin de l'année des
chenaux contrôle plus que 5% de la syrie
parallèlement l'armée irakiennes
appuyées par les forces américaines
l'ibère elle aussi une grande partie de
son territoire ainsi que la capitale
irakienne deux d'âge c'est-à-dire
mossoul fin 2017 et l'irak annoncent
enfin sa victoire militaire sur des jld
après trois ans de combats acharnés ta
victoire est moins facile en syrie
largement battu des djihadistes
maintiennent longtemps le contrôle sur
quelques fortifications il faut
plusieurs mois de combats acharnés pour
qu'en mars 2019 le dernier bastion de
dèche alba gousse un village au sud est
de la syrie tombe et marquent la fin
territoriale de neige dans le pays
l'époque de la super puissance de dèche
est révolue mais ça ne veut pas dire que
son nom sera bientôt oublié en afrique
l'organisation terroriste revendique
désormais ses premiers attentats dans
des piquets auparavant été épargné le
maroc en 2018 la rdc en 2019 et des
groupes terroristes affiliés continuent
de semer la terreur en son nom sur le
continent depuis janvier la principale
menace pour la sécurité du sel
l etat islamique du grand sahara où le
ive s c'est le constat des chefs d'état
de la région et leurs alliés français au
sommet de pau créée en 2015 le groupe
est reconnu par des shows comme sa
branche un an plus tard depuis il monte
en puissance ces derniers mois et il a
revendiqué les attaques les plus
meurtrières de la région au niger au
burkina faso encore au mali me 2019 le
ive s est incorporé dans l'état
islamique en afrique de l'ouest où lee
swaps
c'est en fait le nouveau nom de boko
haram un des plus vieux et redoutable
groupes terroristes sur le continent
active depuis les années 2000 avec pour
but de créer un califat dans le nord du
nigeria boko haram prêtent allégeance à
des chants 2015 et devient lisse wap sa
province ouest africaine en 2018 ce
groupe est classé quatrième le plus
meurtrier au monde et premier en afrique
subsaharienne exécutions de masse
attaques sur les civils et des villages
entiers rasés au cameroun au niger et au
tchad
l'histoire est loin d'être éradiquée
malgré une campagne militaire menée par
cinq pays de la région
8 2015 ce n'est pas par hasard que les
alliés de dèche 100 plants avec autant
de succès dans cette région c'est qu'ils
y trouvent un seul fertile pour leur
idéologie
depuis les années 2000 plusieurs groupes
affiliés à al qaïda opèrent en effet au
sahel et dans les pays limitrophes libye
algérie tunisie
les plus connus sont al-qaïda au maghreb
islamique anne sardines et mouja au
rebaptisé al mourabitoun en 2017
il fusionne et engloutissent plusieurs
petits groupements pour former le groupe
de soutien l'islam et aux musulmans un
réseau transfrontalier affiliés à al
qaïda à l'autre extrémité du continent
en somalie c'est al shabab qui est la
menace principale opposés au pouvoir
central est affilié à al qaïda depuis
2010 ils contrôlent toujours devant
zones rurales de la somalie et mène des
attaques même au delà de ses frontières
dernier exemple en date une attaque
réussie sur la base américaine de manda
bay au kenya au total plus de 200
groupes et groupuscules sont actifs
aujourd'hui en afrique à l'est de
l'afrique une campagne antiterroriste
américaine est en cours et à l'ouest
c'est plutôt la france qui est engagée
sur le terrain en partie grâce à ces
opérations le terrorisme africain tend à
reculer
année après année depuis 2000 14 le
nombre de morts dus à des attentats ne
cesse de baisser
malgré cela le continent demeure parmi
les trois zones les plus menacées du
monde
ce nom ils taisent se trouve de l'autre
côté du globe
c'est l'amérique latine là d'un point de
vue terrorisme il règne un calme relatif
de 2002 à 2018 ce continent a subi au
total un peu plus de 2000 attaques
terroristes qui ont fait 1800 victime ce
qui est relativement peu par rapport à
d'autres classements macabre de rares
attentats sont organisées par des
mouvements locaux de guérilla comme les
forces armées révolutionnaires de
colombie ou farc ou encore l'armée du
peuple paraguayen d'autres attaques sur
le continent sont le fait d'activistes
indigènes comme les mapuches chiliens ou
même des acteurs inconnus ou aux
motivations floues
c'est le cas par exemple pour la bolivie
ou le pérou une sécurité relative qui
s'explique plutôt bien par sa situation
géopolitique selon l'institute for
economics and peace et le terrorisme
frappe surtout des pays en proie à la
guerre civile ont un conflit
transfrontaliers ou faisant face à une
insurrection locale
cependant quid des pays développés
exemple de tels conflits comme l'europe
les états unis ou encore l'australie eh
bien le terrorisme il prend des formes
plutôt particulière
le premier point qui inquiète les
chercheurs est la montée pousse le plan
du nombre des attaques des extrémistes
de droite en cinq ans le nombre
d'attentats commis par eux dans les pays
développés a augmenté de 3 120 % au
total et représente 17 % de tous les
incidents terroristes aux états unis en
europe et en australie en 2018 il
tendance d'autant plus inquiétante que
plus de la moitié des attaques sont
perpétrées par des agresseurs solitaire
ils n'appartiennent à aucun groupe en
particulier sont souvent auto
radicalisés utilisent internet pour
préparer leurs attaques et même en
dehors de l'idéologie de l'extrême
droite le phénomène des terroristes
solitaires se répand de plus en plus en
occident
si les attaques des groupes à idéologie
religieuse comme al qaïda ou dahesh
rester plus meurtrière le nombre total
des attentats dont les auteurs
n'appartiennent à aucun groupe est en
hausse constante
seulement 5% dans les années 70 il
représente plus de 70% de tous les
incidents produit ces cinq dernières
années et c'est de cette fragmentation
de la menace dont s'alarment les
autorités européennes
le rapport publié aujourd'hui montre que
la menace de l'extrémisme
violent provenant de n'importe quelle
idéologie est hétérogène et souple et
continuent de surgir
or d'internet comment faire face à cette
menace multiforme qui n'émane plus d'un
seul acteur la défaite de dèche au
moyen-orient signifie tels que le monde
peut se sentir plus en sécurité
pour mieux comprendre ce qui a vraiment
changé après la victoire proclamée sur
l' état islamique
nous revenons vers notre interview avec
madame caroline galak terros
géopolitologue et présidente de géo
pragma madame ganac terros je voudrais
maintenant aller en amérique latine le
continent a suffisamment de problèmes de
sécurité de criminalité etc
ça devrait être logiquement un terrain
propice au terrorisme pourtant le
terrorisme ici est un niveau assez bas
quand même pourquoi est-il ainsi selon
alors d'abord c'est pour l'instant les
problèmes évidemment de criminalité sont
sont gigantesques sont bien plus
importants d'ailleurs qu'on ne le dit en
amérique latine
mais évidemment il n'y a pas de
terrorisme tel qu on le définit
généralement parce qu'il n'ya pas
vraiment d'implantation non plus
islamique le terrorisme auxquels nous
faisons face en occident au sens large
en europe mais aussi en russie enfin bon
c'est un terrorisme islamique
donc qui s'appuie sur cette idée d'un
islam à la fois politiques et religieux
de d'un tout qui n'a pas pour l'instant
son son ancrage son incarnation en
amérique latine donc c'est pour ça y'a
pas fait jésus à tous les âges à
l'idéologie l'islam qui se sont
peut-être déjà en danger en asie
ne va-t-il pas conquérir d'autres
d'autres continents d'autres pays
que va-t-il faire comment va-t-il se
transformer mais il n'est pas impossible
que
c'est 7 7 ses revendications et ses
craintes il venir habilité bien sûr se
cristallise autour d'une revendication
dit
idéologiquement idéologique et
religieuse avec des modalités terroriste
puisque le terrorisme c'est une modalité
c'est pas c'est pas une espèce en soit
c'est une modalité qui a besoin d'un
socle doctrinal qui a besoin d'une
légitimité symbolique intellectuelle etc
et qui après se manifeste par des
modalités particulières qui consiste
évidemment à provoquer la terreur sur
les populations civiles
je pense qu'on vous dit modalités vous
voulez aussi dire forme et en revenir
sûr sûr sûr sûr une autre forme de cette
radicalisation
en cinq ans le nombre des attentats
commis par des membres des groupes
d'extrême droite a augmenté de 320%
c'est énorme
le phénomène des combattants solitaire
se répand aussi en occident pourquoi
pourquoi cette tendance alors ça je
pense que c'est une autre là on n'est
plus dans le nez plus en terrorisme
islamiste en aidant leurs on est dans
une espèce de manifestations une très
violente est insupportable de réaction à
une déstructuration sociale et je pense
à une manifestation d'appui ans pour ça
que la lutte contre le terrorisme
elle est liée à la résilience de nos
sociétés et à la capacité qu'elles ont
de préserver des collines cohésion
nationale or en europe en tout cas on
assiste à une déstructuration à une
invasion du communautarisme justement à
une fragmentation interne qui est très
très propice
d'abord à des petits groupuscules qui
trouvent leur intérêt et qui promeuvent
leurs propres programmes
et puis surtout à ce qu'on appelle oui
les loups solitaires qui sont jamais
vraiment solitaire parce que même les
loups solitaires
dernier cas en allemagne ryad dans les
bars à chicha
on a eu un peu de mal à qualifier cette
section de terrorisme et finalement on
l'a qualifié d' acte terroriste alors
c'est un acteur us déjà au sens où oui
c'est un set un acte de terreur
vis-à-vis d'une population innocente qui
est là et qui d'un seul coup et victime
de ce cas ça c'est certain
deuxièmement je pense que l'ajustement
le l'état en fait c'est lié à la
modernité aussi cela c'est à dire c'est
lié à nos sociétés qui promeuvent
tellement l'individualisme que ça
produit de l' isolement
pour les plus faibles parce que
l'individualisme c'est bien quand on en
a les moyens
entre guillemets quand on a les skieuses
quand on a les capacités de la mobilité
intellectuels professionnels spatiale
avant quand on n'a pas tout ça on est
juste tout seul perdu voire désespérée
et on prend de plein fouet
je pense le spectacle médiatique enfin
que les médias relaient et bien de tous
ces mouvements de tout de toutes ces
idées de remplacement des populations de
l'invasion migratoire il ya tout ça
alors et tout ça ça a créé des vocations
entre guillemets mais des vocations qui
sont basées sur des sur des souffrances
sur des impossibilités sur d impuissance
merci beaucoup caroline galatée rose
d'avoir été là d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelais vous étiez plutôt
longue et président de géo pragma merci
encore bien merci
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]